nice la parole est à monsieur bernard
gérard monsieur le président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur premier ministre alors que nos
institutions régaliennes n'ont plus les
moyens vous engagé depuis le début de ce
mandat dans des réformes qui conforte le
désordre
sur le terrain les fonctions régaliennes
que sont la sécurité la justice si on
santé sont au bord de l'implosion
et voilà maintenant que la loi notre
vient poser plus de questions qu'elle
n'apporte de solutions avec un mépris
des élus locaux met en lumière dans les
débats parlementaires au motif que je
cite le parlement un pouvoir supérieur à
celui des élus locaux
tout est dis vous avez raté cette
réforme ritter royal ce texte ne répond
pas aux problèmes liés au millefeuille
territorial il ne clarifie pas les
compétences et faute de dialogue il crée
un malaise profond dans le monde rural
bref loin d'être un texte structurants
il génère plus d'inquiétude plus de
complexité et cette fois s'annonce déjà
comme un rendez vous manqué les élus
régionaux départementaux les maires le
monde rural sont en colère ils ont
raison de l'être car ce projet de loi
dont j'étais petit fini ciel était la
suppression du département au profit de
région puissante re met avant tout en
cause les équilibres qui prévalait entre
communes et intercommunalités et vise à
éloigner la décision du lieu où elle
s'appliquera suppression de la notion
d'intérêt communautaire taille
déraisonnable des intercommunalités
multiplication des transferts
obligatoire de compétences le tout dans
un calendrier intenable pour les
territoires c'est un certitude que le
projet de loi laisse perdurer s'ajoutent
aux baisses de taux d'accès dotation
drastiques imposées aux collectivités
qui sont un coup de massue pour les
mères et pour la démocratie locale
quoi que vous prétendiez le maintien de
la poutre la totalité des services
publics locaux est menacée et
l'investissement public local chute
lourdement
plutôt que d'écouter et d'accepter de
discuter d'un rééchelonnement ou fermer
la porte et vous brutaliser les élus
locaux
comment votre gouvernement peut-il
multiplient à ce point les erreurs de
fond de forme et de méthode
la pole est à madame marylise lebranchu
ministre de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique tant les dames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bernard gérard
nous avons eu effectivement de très
longs débats et la question majeure qui
nous est posée c'est peut-on considérer
aujourd'hui que 29 min communes de moins
de 1000 habitants
plus de 15000 communes de moins de 500
habitants peuvent faire face aux
demandes de services publics de leurs
concitoyens je ne le crois pas est ce
qu'il ya eu de vrais progrès de fait
dans l'intercommunalité rançon doute
est-ce que nous avons encore des
possibilités de mutualiser les services
avons nous des possibilités d'avancer
vers les services petite enfance en
commun on en a souvent parlé ensemble
pendant les débats allaient halte
garderie avant nous les moyens de
répondre au fait monsieur le député que
nous syndicats locaux par exemple dont
les budgets sont de 17 milliards d'euros
on dansait budget 9 milliards d'euros de
frais de fonctionnement
lorsque très souvent leurs périmètres
sont proches les établissements publics
intercommunaux
je pense que face à des réalités nous
pouvons faire des propositions nous les
avons longuement discuté des
départements ont été maintenus égard de
grandes compétences puisqu'il s'agit des
collèges des routes et sans doute et
c'est très important des solidarités
territoriales
nous avons tenté ensemble je vois que je
n'y ai pas réussi d'expliquer à quel
point on allait avec la conférence
territoire et son public progressé mais
je crois monsieur les députés que le
pire que le pire serait de dire à
l'ensemble des maires ruraux en
particulier des communautés de communes
rurales qu'ils pourront progresser en
terme de service public sans être
réhabilité sans l'effort des uns et des
autres ça c'est vraiment considérer
qu'il faut rester immobile ne rien
toucher que tout se passera bien de
maintenant nous avons besoin de
progresser de moderniser de faire en
commun et très honnêtement après 140
desmans monsieur le député je pas que
les choses avancent
la parole est à monsieur gaby charroux